hi there
steve kaufman here uh a little different
today i'm standing in front of a print
here of a cafe i think it's called cafe
le soir which was painted by van gogh or
van gogh or whatever his name is dutch
painter in southern france
it's an image of language takes you to
exotic places and you can mix different
cultures and that's what i love about it
but
today i want to talk about long-term
versus short-term
activities or strategies in language
learning and i thought about it because
i was reflecting on my farsi experience
where i've really been
kind of hitting farsi hard since i came
back from morocco prior to that i've
been working on arabic now i'm doing
sort of three days a week of farsi three
days a week of arabic
but
even with this limited exposure to farsi
i am having conversations with my tutor
and i am speaking and i'm able to
express things and i'll show you that
later on in a couple of weeks or so
as a part of our 90-day
challenge and the sort of daily clinic
that we're going to do
people are saying when will the daily
clinic what time of the day we haven't
decided yet it's a little bit uncertain
we'll have to feel our way to that and i
will be letting you know here once we
get into the 90-day challenge how all of
this is going to work so just stay tuned
at this
channel but
long term versus short term which is
also something to consider as we go into
a 90 day challenge what are we trying to
achieve so if i compare farsi to check
check despite having learned russian and
having a lot of the vocabulary
and uh you know having all kinds of
advantages it was eight months before i
spoke to a tutor and then i struggled
mightily all right whereas with farsi
but i had a lot of words like right now
and check i have 40 50 000 words
according to our statistics at link in
farsi i have less than 1400 words i
believe i just checked
and yet i'm speaking in farsi
so
why well one thing i've done in farsi is
that i have i have these many stories so
i've listened to them 30 40 50 times so
i have quite a good grasp on a more
limited amount of vocabulary
and part of the reason i do that is
because farsi is intrinsically more
difficult than czech because czech is
written in the latin alphabet farsi is
written in the arabic alphabet it's more
difficult to read therefore in farsi
with czech i had more sort of accessible
sort of intermediate
although it was still difficult but it
was easier to get into authentic content
more difficult to do in farsi
plus i'm motivated to speak to all the
farsi speakers
in vancouver whereas there's no check
speakers for me to talk to in vancouver
so i had two different goals
uh
i know
that even though i can speak to my farsi
speaking tutor
is a long way before i really be able to
understand you know uh news podcasts
radio programs and that kind of thing
because to do that in any language
requires a lot of vocabulary i do
eventually want to get there so
the time that i'm spending on improving
my short term ability to speak is time
that's taking away taken away from
building up enough vocabulary to be able
to read newspaper articles on politics
and so forth
in the case of arabic i'm starting to do
more of you know fighting my way through
al jazeera you know online newspaper
articles
but i still do i still go back to my
repetitive listening of many stories
which are tremendously powerful in terms
of building up your ability to speak so
uh if i have a need to speak now i don't
really have a big need to speak to
arabic speak in arabic and in particular
in modern modern standard arabic so that
my goal there is still somewhat more
passive in terms of wanting to build up
enough vocabulary so that i can follow
things on the internet
whereas in farsi my goal is much more
short term just to be able to converse
with people in farsi so i think it's
important that we have a strategy like
what do we want to achieve the ability
to say a few things in the language in
the short term
if that's all you want to achieve then
you put all your emphasis on that if you
want to also build up your ability to
watch movies and
follow
stuff on the internet then you have to
force yourself into some of those sort
of
longer term activities
acquiring more vocabulary you can't
listen i can't listen to these podcasts
20 30 times they're too long
i give myself some exposure to these
podcasts after having in arabic after
having worked through the text but it's
still very very fuzzy for me just as it
was when i was learning czech month
after month after month i was struggling
to understand the material that i was
listening to
and yet slowly slowly slowly you get
better i should also say that in my
repetitive listening to my even my
arabic and my farsi mini stories
every time i listen
i focus on something else i discover
something else i discover a phrase i
knew but i hadn't really focused on it
or a structure and so that it's i still
find it
compelling in a way to
spend some of my time
working on this basic material to get a
better grip on a natural grip on some of
the structures of the language
and combine that in the case of arabic
with pushing my vocabulary forward
whereas in farsi i'm still more or less
focused on
you know the most common verbs of the
language which appear in our 60
mini-story so um that's kind of what i
wanted to say i think all of us have to
decide based on our goals whether we
want to put more time into the sort of
short-term objectives
or invest in the long-term because
eventually we will be able to speak it's
just that we won't be able to say very
much up front if we're focusing on
on building up our vocabulary for the
long term
so there you have it and uh you know
next friday we start the 90-day
challenge so once again people can study
any language they want i will be holding
regular clinics where i will be showing
you what i am doing
my 90-day challenge is a
for the first time two languages
arabic and farsi
but most people will be doing one
language
and i'll be talking about what i'm doing
and
we will decide on a time of day for
those of you
this is for my clinics those of you who
want to join me
i'm not sure how this is going to work
we will find out as we get into it so
thank you for listening and uh yeah
today's
monday thursday will be my last
regular video until we get into our 90
day challenge starting next friday
oh and i almost forgot
um i'm going to fukuoka in the fall for
the polyglot conference there fukuoka
japan
and i was contacted by a lady who worked
for
the canadian broadcasting corporation
uh the cbc
who which has a program called the
nature of things with david suzuki and
they're doing a program on polyglots and
she would like to hear from any
polyglots anyone who speaks two or more
languages
who is prepared to sort of tackle
learning japanese that is to say anyone
who is going to fukuoka i think that's
what she wants or otherwise interested
in working on japanese because she wants
to
somehow interview these people or keep
track of or understand better how these
polyglots would go about learning
japanese in a lead up to the fukuoka
polyglot conference so if you are at all
interested in contacting eileen is her
name i will leave her email address in
the description box here thank you bye
[Music]
you